welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Vladimir Alexandrov the be e Benson
your professor of Slavic languages and
literatures at Yale University he is an
expert on 19th and 20th century Russian
prose especially the works of Leo
Tolstoy Andre Belly and Vladimir Nabokov
and on literary theory professor
Alexandrov is the author of a number of
scholarly books and publications and has
received several notable awards today we
talk with professor Alexandrov about his
new book The Black Russian which
recently won the Macmillan Center's
Gustav Ranas International Book Prize
welcome professor Alexandrov thank you
very much let's begin with an overview
of your book tell us about it
it's a biography of an absolutely
remarkable man he was the son of former
slaves in Mississippi who became a
multi-millionaire entrepreneur in
Czarist Moscow lost everything in the
Bolshevik Revolution of 1917 and
reestablished himself in Constantinople
as the sultan of jazz
Wow and this is quite a departure for
you from the other books you have
written what led you to write it it was
an accident that changed my life and I
remember the moment very clearly because
I was preparing to teach a graduate
seminar on Russian emigre culture
between the wars and I was reading the
memoirs of a Russian singer who is very
popular in the late nineteen teens and
1920s who described how when he escaped
from the south of Russia he wound up in
Constantinople and began to perform and
I'll translate what he said in Russian
into English for our famous Moscow Negro
Philadelphia derivatives this was so
unexpected that I remember literally
closing the book and putting it down
because for various historical reasons
they were very
few black people in Imperial Russia
whether from Africa the Caribbean or the
United States
I knew the period I knew something about
the culture and I was so intrigued that
I decided to study it and this led me to
do work in archives and libraries and
six countries and was quite a trip I bet
I bet so how did he get to Russia from
Mississippi he broke the mold for people
of his background at every step of his
life when his family fell apart in
Memphis
in 1890 when his father was brutally
murdered he went north which was long
before the large migration of black
people from the south to the northern
part of the United States in 1894 he did
something else that was very much ahead
of the curve for black Americans seeking
greater freedom he went to Europe and he
picked up languages very easily
apparently enjoyed working as a waiter
in a valet which was a very portable
skill until in 1898 he came across a
rich Russian in Montecarlo who offered
him a job as a valet in st. Petersburg
and that's how Thomas his name is
Frederick Bruce Thomas came to Russia
initially and after that his personal
life and his career just skyrocketed so
you know how did he become to be so
famous I mean he sounds like a
fascinating man he was I think what he
did is first of all he was a very bright
man and very good at dealing with people
he was a wonderful psychologist and he
sort of brought the quintessence of
southern hospitality
to Russia and amplified it here an
popular entertainment venues popular
gardens that would have all kinds of
theaters and entertainments in theaters
themselves restaurants he was a great
host great attention to detail and he
was able to make a success of a business
that was a very difficult business to be
in in those days there's a lot of
competition
and was this in Russia he was doing yeah
he started out as a waiter in Russia
around 1900 by 1911 he started to take
off on his own with some Russian
partners within a year of his opening
his first business he'd made in today's
dollars over a million dollars in clear
profit which he plowed into other
investments which were also extremely
successful so for popular entertainment
light operas musical performances light
plays farces and so on a good food lots
of champagne vaudeville performances of
different kinds he was one of the
leading figures in Imperial Russia just
before it all came crashing down in 1917
was he an entertainer himself or just a
kind of a man behind it he had actually
studied singing and his family members
his sons in particular always sang later
on but he was an entrepreneur so he
wasn't the actual draw onstage but the
one who organized their own he had a
great talent for importing to Moscow
successful acts from all over Europe and
even from the United States so I'm
curious how did you manage to find out
the details of his life I was lucky that
he left a paper trail because you can
frequently come across interesting
people who for various reasons didn't
leave traces after them but Frederic
Thomas did because he was successful in
Moscow and when he got to Constantinople
which is what Istanbul used to be called
as you know he had a lot of dealings
with the American consulate general in
that city and it was my wonderful
fortune that the secretaries in that
consulate generals kept every last scrap
of paper
pertaining to Frederic Thomas's affairs
that were delivered to their offices or
that he sent to them and they're all in
the National Archives in Washington DC
so I was able to find a great deal of
information but it was fortunate that he
left the patient room
I am curious in writing a biography and
and doing the research and piecing
together someone's life do you ever
worry about getting something wrong all
the time yeah absolutely and the only
thing one can do is to be as diligent as
possible to throw your net as widely as
possible to try to cross-reference
details I one of the things that was a
great challenge but also a very
appealing part of writing this up was to
be truthful to the factors I knew them
without modifying or exaggerating
anything and so if I was unsure about
something that somebody said about him I
tried to hedge it in the way that I
expressed it without constantly saying
it seems that or one could suppose
something else
so it's cross referencing things and
being very wary as you walk the thin
edge between invention and facts so were
there people in his life at the time
that you could also research to get
information about him there were and
actually one of the most interesting
people that he was friends with was a
very famous black American boxer Jack
Johnson who had become the world
heavyweight champion in 1910 in the
United States had had a terrible time
because of the racial barriers in the
professional boxing world the white
champions wouldn't want to meet him in
the ring but when he did fight them he
won and he was constantly hounded in the
United States during the nineteen
nineteen teens and Frederick reached out
to him from Moscow when Jack Johnson was
being run out of Chicago Frederick
offered him a gig in Moscow to put on
exhibition matches which Johnson
accepted except that he didn't get to
Russia until 1914 right on the eve of
the Great War so they were able to
become friends but none of the matches
that were planned which would have been
a major event in both entertainment and
sport in Russia and in Europe never took
place
but yes Jack Johnson is very
well-documented he's a very well known
figure so I was able to find people like
that and lesser ones too
now for having been so infamous I'll say
during his life he's relatively unknown
now whereas other people like for the
boxer for instance have stood the test
of time so to speak why do you think
that is
yeah Frederick Thomas was pretty much
forgotten when he died in 1928 and my
book is the only study of him that
exists it's an attempt to bring him back
to public memory I think there are
several reasons one is American racism
we're talking about a period in American
history when the achievements of black
people were not actively celebrated by
the white press and other media of the
time also Frederick by this point was
living halfway around the world in
Turkey so he was not as omnipresent as
say Jack Johnson was in the United
States and Turkey also had changed by
this point because in 1923 the Turkish
Republic was proclaimed it turned
against being exceptionally nice to
foreigners the way the old Ottoman
Empire used to be and so even within the
new Turkish context there was no
interest in celebrating a prominent
foreigner so he fell in between the
historical cracks as it were although he
had been famous during his life one way
in which I can mention is that when
American tourists came to Constantinople
in the 1920s they all wanted to do the
same thing but tourists still want to do
their now they want to go see Hagia
Sophia they want to go to the Grand
Bazaar and in those days they all wanted
to go to Frederick Thomas's nightclub to
hear some really good jazz and to have a
really stiff drink because prohibition
was enforced in the States I say but
once he disappeared from the scene
people forgot about him so ultimately
what did happen to him his end was
tragic
he overextended himself after have
become successful in Constantinople he
opened ventures that did not succeed
there was too much competition his
creditors seized his properties he had
no protection from the Americans in
Turkey who had washed their hands of him
fundamentally for race racial reasons
and he was put in to debtors prison
where he contracted pneumonia and where
he died and he was buried in
Constantinople I know the cemetery where
he was buried and then very shortly
thereafter memory of him completely
faded well it's nice that you've brought
him back to life
no it was I really enjoyed the project
and I understand you know you have been
offered a couple of different
opportunities on the large screen
perhaps maybe in miniseries and a
musical talk about that that's that's a
lot of fun of course several individuals
and companies have expressed interest in
the possibility of either doing a
feature film or frankly what is now more
appealing is doing a TV miniseries
because that's where a lot of creative
energy is going so you know many books
are called very few are chosen so we'll
see what happens
but it's promising uh-huh what is more
certain is a musical version of Frederic
Thomas's story which was solicited from
me by an entertainment and hospitality
company in New York and over the summer
I wrote a script for that okay there are
nine songs I worked with the composer at
the company to come up with period
appropriate styles of music early 1920s
jazz Russian gypsy style music things
like that and I wrote the lyrics to the
music that he composed we went back and
forth it's going to be a kind of a
cabaret style one-man show initially
that should be staged in New York at
some point in late fall or winter and if
that seems successful the idea is to try
to develop it into a full-fledged
musical very exciting now it must have
been
I'm very interesting for you I mean I
would imagine heavy
ever written any lyrics or a script
before well I've written narrative I
hadn't really tried my hand at writing
any kind of a play like form I did write
poetry I did study poetry a lot and
analyzed it a lot in my teaching so it
turned out to be not as much of a
stretch to write the lyrics as I also
thought it would be when this first came
up and it proved to be a lot of fun I
bet the music was very well composed
that the composer was very talented in
finding just the right kind of music for
what I wanted to do and it was a very
enjoyable process well we will look
forward to that
coming out great all right thank you so
much for being here with us today and
sharing some of your work thank you it's
my pleasure for more information about
Professor Alexandre and his research
please visit our website at Yale edu
slash macmillan report be sure to join
us again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale